GET STARTED AS SOON AS WE HAVE.
ONE ADDITIONAL MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AND IF ANY OF THOSE MEMBERS ARE
WATCHING IN THEIR OFFICE RIGHT
NOW.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO COME DOWN SO
WE GET STARTED THANKS
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY WERE
GONNA START.
THIS MORNING'S ELECTIONS IN
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE HEARING
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. ALLOWED TO
HAVE ANY ANNOUNCEMENTS OR WAS
GOING STRAIGHT TO.
THAT'S GREAT US SO FIRST UP.
NOW WE HAVE A DEVIL OF A BILL.
BY MY COLLEAGUE.
HOME IS THAT WE ARE CURRY.
BILL NUMBER SIX SIX SIX.
THE TOO EARLY.
WE GOT TO GET THIS COFFEE IF
PEOPLE.
MAN I THINK IN THE PLOT YEAH
RIGHT.
READY WHENEVER YOU ARE OK GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
YEAR COMMITTEE STAFFER WORK WITH
MY OFFICE AND I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES DRAFTED AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY THE BILL.
AB SIX SIX SIX IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD PROPOSAL
INSPIRED BY THE SITUATION THEMY
COLLEAGUES AND I WHO REPRESENT
MULTIPLE COUNTS EXPERIENCE EVERY
ELECTION SEASON.
ALL START BY EXPLAINING WHAT AB
SIX SIX SIX MEANS TO ME.
SIX COUNTIES.
SIX DIFFERENT FORMS TO FILL OUT
AND SUBMIT.
AND SIX DIFFERENT WAYS TO SUBMIT
ALL THAT PAPERWORK.
THIS BILL TODAY IS THE FIRST
STEP TOWARD FINDING A WAY TO
STREAMLINE THIS OVERWHELMING
PROCESS.
FOR NEW AND NOVICE CANDIDATES
WHO ARE UNFAMILIAR WITH THE
DAUNTING AND COMPLICATED STEPS
TO QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT.
I'M WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
SECRETARY OF STATE AND MY LOCAL
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO ENSURE.
THAT WORK WHERE WE GO WITH A B.
SIX SIX SIX IS COLLABORATIVE.
YOU MAY THINK I'M CRAZY FOR
TRYING TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
EVEN TO CHALLENGE ME. BUT I PLAN
TO PURSUE A REASONABLE SOLUTION
THAT WORKS FOR ALL OF US
REGARDLESS OF PARTY BACKGROUND
OR RESOURCES.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OUR WITNESSES WHO ARE STILL.
WITH SOME THOUGHTS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBER SILVIO FRYING
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
CLERKS ELECTION OFFICIALS OUT
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INVOLVEMENT ON THIS ISSUE A WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION
BUT THE AUTHORS OPPOSITE AND
REACHING OUT TO A SINCE LAST
YEAR WHICH WE. GREATLY
APPRECIATED A WE HAVE ELECTION
OFFICIALS COMING TO TOWN NEXT
WEEK TO SIT DOWN WITH THE AUTHOR
STAFF REALLY TALK THROUGH THIS
AND SEE IF THERE IS A. WAY FOR
THAT EVERYONE I CAN BE HAPPY
WITH SO THAT IT IS STREAMLINED.
SO GET LOOK FOR TO THAT
HOPEFULLY BY THE NINETEENTH.
WILL HAVE SOME MORE DETAIL SO
WE CAN BEGIN TO TAKE FORMAL
POSITION THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
GREG THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE C COME ON UP TO DO
WE HAVE.
MICROPHONE
RIGHT.
OUTSIDE JUST RIGHT HERE IS GREAT
YEAH.
YOU THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE GREAT
MORNING MY NAME'S MICHAEL
FEINSTEIN A FORMER MAYOR AND
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN SANTA
MONICA COFOUNDER THE GREEN PARTY
AND CANDIDATE FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE. I WANNA RAISE SINCE THE
SECT THIS BILL DEALS WITH THE
SECTION OF THE CODE DEALING WITH
CANDID STATEMENTS I WANNA RAISE
THE VOTER RIGHTS ISSUE. THAT THE
CURRENT TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR FEE
FOR THE CANDID STATEMENT PER
WORD MAKES THE COST PROHIBITIVE
FOR A LOT OF CANDIDATES AND.
THAT'S A VOTERS RIGHT TO KNOW
OUR CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONS
SAYS THE.
POWER IS ALL IN HERE IN THE
PEOPLE AND YET VOTERS WHO GO TO
THE POLLS DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
A BASE LEVEL OF INFORMATION
ABOUT ALL CANDIDATES ON THEIR
BALLOTS. THAT'S A PROBLEM SECOND
THE SECRETARY OF STATE ACTUALLY
SETS THE FEE YET WITH SECRETARY
OF STATE IS SAYING THE FEE. THAT
WOULD THEN POSSIBLY RECRUIT
PRECLUDE OR UNDERMINE THE
ABILITY OF A CANDIDATE RUNNING
AGAINST THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
TO HAVE A FULL CANDIDATES
STATEMENT THAT'S A DIRECT
CONFLICT OF INTERESTS AND
INAPPROPRIATE SO I'M HOPING
YOU'LL DO DURING THE COURSE OF
THIS BILL. IS TO LOOK AT AN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD LOWER THE
FEE AND LOOK AT IT NOT FROM A
TRANSACTIONAL DYNAMIC WHICH SAYS
ALL THIS IS A GREAT BARGAIN FOR
A CANDIDATE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
A.
CANDIDATE STATEMENT IN THE IN
THE VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE OR
IN THE COUNTY GUIDES BUT INSTEAD
THIS IS A RIGHT FOR ALL VOTERS
TO HAVE A BASELINE SET OF
INFORMATION. AND AND THAT'S
REALLY I THINK A PRINCIPAL THAT
UNDERLIE OUR DEMOCRACY I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND I
SPENT THREE AND A HALF YEARS AS
A RESIDENT REFINED CITY AND MISS
THOSE DAYS YEAH. IF THE GREAT
CITY OF MUCH
SO WITH THAT I THINK A QUICK
BREAK BECAUSE I BELIEVE A WARM
AND SUGGEST MADAM SECRETARY TO
TAKE THE ROLE.
BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE HARPER
PRESENT
HARPER HERE CULTURAL.
LOW.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON PATTERSON HERE WEBER
HERE
WEBER HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A AND I
THINK YOU FOR FOR WORKING WITH
WITH MY OFFICE IN MY TEAM ON I'M
MAKING A COUPLE TREES I JUST
WANNA CONFIRM BECAUSE.
I DIE MADE THINGS A LOT MORE
COMPLICATED.
LATE IN THE GAME THAT.
.
COMMON UBER FIVE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS FOR THIS BILL SUGGESTS
AN AMENDMENT THAT LIMITS THE
APPLICATION OF THIS BILL TO
SITUATIONS WHERE THE ERROR IN
THE CANDIDATE STATEMENT FORM.
DOES NOT DEPRIVE THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL OF INFORMATION NEEDED
TO COMPLY WITH STATE LAW WELL I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH THAT
SENTIMENT.
THE SLIGHT TWEAK THAT I
SUGGESTED THAT I THINK WE RAN BY
OUR OFFICE DONE PRIOR TO THE
HEARING IS THAT WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THE BILL CONTINUE TO
PROHIBIT AN ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
FROM REJECTING A FORM. THAT HAS
BEEN POSTED TO THE OFFICIAL
WEBSITE BUT THAT THE BILL BE
AMENDED TO ALLOW THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL TO REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM A CANDIDATE IF
NECESSARY. TO COMPLY WITH STATE
LAW SO THEY CAN'T REJECT THE
FOREMAN OR STOP A PERSON FROM
FILING FOR AND I CAN FOLLOW UP
RIGHT IN THE SENATE THE
FRUSTRATION THAT I FOUND IN
PERSONALLY MYSELF MY CAMPAIGN
MANAGER AND WE ARE GOING. SIX
COUNTIES AND EACH IT EACH EMAIL
WEBSITE WERE DIFFERENT YEAH.
AND THEN YOU WOULD GO IN WITH
THE FORM OFF THE WEBSITE NEVER
SO THOSE INCORRECT ONE AND THEN
JUST START A WHOLE PROCESS SO. I
THINK MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS
HERE IN THIS BUILDING I THINK
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO FILE ONCE
YEAH WHEN YOU HAVE NUMEROUS CUT
COUNTY SO. PRINCES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW HAS LIKE
ELEVEN COUNTIES AND HE'S GOT TO
DO ELEVEN DIFFERENT FORMS AS
WELL AS MISTER DALI SO. I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE AS HECK EVEN
PLAYING FIELD WE MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PEOPLE TO WANT TO RUN YEAH
THEIR DEGREE WITH YOU A HUNDRED
PERCENT AS AS SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT OF OF TWO
COUNTIES NOT SIX. OR LEMON
TOTALLY JUMP THE GUN YES SIR.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WELL I I JUST I HAVE IT UP FOR
THE RECORD LOVE.
WHICH WHICH OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEING INCLUDED.
OR MY DOCUMENTATION NO I DON'T
HAVE BEEN PRONE.
YOU HAVE THE MORE THAT.
WE'LL HAVE THE MOCK UP YET.
BECAUSE IT THE THE ONE NINE
SPECIFICALLY ASKING ABOUT IS THE
AMENDMENT TO CONSIDER AND.
TO CONSIDER TO MAKE PROVISIONS
THE BILL APPLICABILITY ANY
CANDIDATE STATEMENT THAT THE
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIAL POSTS
ON HIS OR HER WEBSITE REGARDLESS
OF THE OFFICE THAT THE CANDIDATE
IS SEE.
IS THAT.
IF I CAN CLARIFY. UNION OFFICE
CORRECT OKAY SO THAT'S THAT'S
NOT BEEN CHANGED
THAT.
SHE LIVES. IN IS ACCEPTING ALL
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE YOU KNOW.
ALRIGHT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY THAT HELPED
HER FIGHT FOR ME THINK OKAY
SORRY WE DIDN'T CLARIFY THAT
THAT'S THAT'S QUITE ALRIGHT.
THE GREAT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST THINK IT WOULD BE JUST
WONDERFUL THAT WE GET THIS
THROUGH I KNOW WE NEED TO TWEAK
ITS MARKETS AMENDMENTS BUT THE
FACT THE MATTER IS IS THAT I
WANTED TO BE FAIR FOR EVERYONE.
NO MATTER WHO THEY ARE TO BE
ABLE TO
.
A MOTION I'LL SECOND.
WE PLEASE CALL ROOM.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE HARPER
AYE.
HARPER AYE CALLED THE ROOM.
LOW.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON PATTERSON AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
OKAY SO THAT YEAH AS A FOR A
VOTE AND AND WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER SAT ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME THANK YOU.
AND NEXT UP WE HAVE.
MR STEINORTH WITH A. B. SIX SIX
FOUR.
MORNING.
YOU WERE YOU WERE CLOSE TO IS
THE WORD SKATING CLOSE TO SIX
SIX SIX A CLOSE BY AND WE WE GOT
THERE JUST IN THE NICK OF TIME.
MONOPOLY EVIL HERE YEAH
FAVOURITE FIRST ONE TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AYE MR TURNED
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THINK CAUCUS
STAFF AND GIVE ME THAT A
COMMITTEE STAFFER REALLY WORKING
WITH US TO TRY AND. MODIFY THIS
BILL SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
WILL BE ACCEPTABLE FOR EVERYONE
HERE.
AB SIX SIX FOR ITS INTENT IS TO
CLARIFY THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT
FOR CAMPAIGN INVESTIGATIONS.
I'M SO I WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT
CURRENTLY PREVENTS A CANDIDATE'S
SPOUSE OR DOMESTIC PARTNER FROM
RECEIVING CAMPAIGN FUNDS.
BUT A LOOPHOLE HAS LED TO A LACK
OF CLARITY IN AT PPC
INVESTIGATIONS.
BECAUSE THERE LEGAL
INTERPRETATION OF LOS NOT
EXPLICITLY STATED IN THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT.
TODAY THE LEGISLATURE'S ABLE TO
PROVIDE CLARITY FOR CALIFORNIAS
CAMPAIGN INVESTIGATIVE BODY BY
CODIFYING COMMON PRACTICE.
IT IS OUR DUTY TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS DO NOT USE OUR
CANDIDACY TO UNDULY ENRICH THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS.
SERVING IN ELECTED OFFICE IS A
PRIVILEGE
AND OUR CONSTITUENTS DESERVE THE
UTMOST TRANSPARENCY IN HOW
CANDIDATES CHOOSE TO SPEND THEIR
CAMPAIGN DOLLARS.
BY ELIMINATING THIS LOOPHOLE IN
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EMBRACE
TRANSPARENCY FOR BOTH OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND FOR THE F.
PPC.
I AM JOINED TODAY BY NICOLAS
HIGH TORN FROM THE COMMON CAUSE
A NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO ELECTION
TRANSPARENCY.
THE ONE THING THAT A GREAT
THANKS VERY MUCH.
SHARE MEMBERS NICKEL SITE ON
WITH CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
FIRST HAVE A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
STACY MONEY SIMILAR FACES IS
ALSO NEW FACES.
ARE COURSE THE PURPOSE OF
SOLICITING CAMPAIGN DONATIONS A
SLOW CAN IT'S GET THEIR MESSAGE
OUT TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
FOR WHY THEY SHOULD BE ELECTED.
IF I CAN THAT WE'RE TO POCKET
CAMPAIGN FUNDS IT WOULD BE NOT
ONLY DISPIRITING TO THE MARK SEE
WOULD ALSO OPEN THE DOOR TO
CORRUPTION BECAUSE IN ANY
DONATION FROM SPECIAL INTERESTS.
BE DIRECTLY ENRICHING THAT
CANDID INTENSELY FUTURE ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
OF COURSE FOR THAT REASON
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS CAN IT'S
FROM A HEIGHT REACHING
THEMSELVES OF CAMPAIGN FUNDS AS
LONG. AS WELL AS OUR SPOUSES.
AND OF COURSE SO IT'S NO BIG
STEP THOUGH TO SEE WHETHER BE
SIMILAR CONCERN WITH PEOPLE IN
REACHING THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
I IMPOSING A LIMIT OF REQUIRING
PEOPLE TO HAVE ACTUALLY PERFORM
SERVICES AND RECEIVING A MORE
THAN FAIR MARKET VALUE HELPS
LIMIT THE POTENTIAL FOR THAT
ABUSE.
IT ALSO GIVES THE EFFICACY
MANAGEABLE STANDARD OF SENSHI
REQUIRING HONEST PAY FOR HONEST
WORK.
BUT AS COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
CORRECTLY NOTES THIS.
BILL CODIFIES AN AS EASILY MORE
MENTION THIS CODIFIES EXISTING
PRACTICE FOUND IN THE FTP SEES
HARDEN ADVICE LETTER.
A WE THINK CONVOCATION MAKES AND
THAT SENSE IN THIS CASE PERSON
PROVIDES MORE NOTICE TO REGULATE
COMMUNION CAMPAIGNS THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WITH LOCAL
CAMPAIGNS WHO. WON'T HAVE OFTEN
WON'T HAVE PAID PROFESSIONAL
STAFF TO HELP THEM.
A SECOND PROVIDES MORE
PROTECTION FOR WHAT WE BELIEVE
IS IMPORTANT RULE BY CODIFYING
THIS.
YOU PROVIDE MORE SECURITY THAT
THE SCHOOL WILL CONTINUE BECAUSE
OF COURSE VICE LETTERS CAN COME
AND GO AT THE U. PLEASURE OF THE
COMMISSION.
FINALLY LASSEN ONE MENTIONWHICH
IS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED WITHIN THE
COMMITTEE HOUSES IS OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF HARDENED GENERALLY
SAYING THAT ALL CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURES MUST BE FAIR MARKET
VALUE. AS NOT VITIATED BY
PASSING THIS BILL THAT WOULD OF
COURSE CONTINUE INTO FACT AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO PREVENT
CRONYISM.
OR OTHER TYPES OF CAMPAIGN
FINANCE ABUSE NOT RELATING TO
MEDIAN FAMILY MEMBERS FOR THOSE
REASONS WE THINK THERE'S A
VALUABLE ADDITION POLITICAL FOR
MAX AND WE'RE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OPEN UP THE COLLEAGUES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISS HARPER.
WHAT I THINK?
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BACK I THINK THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR WORK. I IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO ACHIEVE
CONSENSUS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
A SOLUTION.
THANK MR ARBOR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'M JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
IN AGAIN IF I COULD JUST.
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE FOR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND WORKING WITH
US INTO THE CHAIRMAN FOR HELPING
US BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD THANK YOU. MOVE THE
BILL.
SECOND.
THEN AND NOW EXPRESS MY THANKS
TO YOU MR STEINORTH FOR YOU KNOW
IT WELL LENGTHY DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS BILL AND IN COMMITTEE AND
OUTSIDE A COMMITTEE AND.
YOU KNOW REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH MY STAFF WITH ME
OVER THE BREAK TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE ON.
AND IF I CAN'T USE HIS CAMPAIGN
FUNDS TO PAY A FAMILY MEMBER FOR
CAMPAIGN WORK IT IS IS
REASONABLE ON AN APPROPRIATE TO
EXPECT THAT THE AMOUNT PAID WILL
BECOME ANSWER WITH THE WORK
THAT'S PERFORMED.
AND THAT'S THAT ALSO CONSISTENT
WITH LONGSTANDING FD PC ADVICE
SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL WITH THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED IN COMMON SUMMER FIVE
NUMBER SIX OF THE ANALYSIS.
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU PLEASE CULTURAL OR GOT
A CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE BERMAN
AYE HARPER AYE. HARPER AYE
CALDERONE.
LOW. LOW AYE MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
SO THE VOTERS FROM THE FIVE ZERO
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR DISMEMBER
SAT ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE.
AB THREE OH SIX BY AS A MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
ALL THAT GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING.
AND
THINK YOU. AND AYE YOU WANNA
START ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
SUGGEST AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY A
THE DESIGNEES FAILURE TO RETURN
ABOUT WITHIN THE TIMELINES
IMPOSED BY THIS BILL. AND THAT
THE BALLOT IF IT'S OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE WOULD.
STILL BE ELIGIBLE I'M I THIS IS
JUST A CLEANUP BILL FROM.
FROM A BILL WE DIDN'T TWENTY
SIXTEEN THAT ALLOWS BASICALLY
THE VOTER DECIDE WHO TURNS IN
THE BALLOT THAT THEY CAN
DESIGNATE ANYONE TO TURN IN
THEIR BALLOT IT'S IT'S A A
PERSONAL CHOICE.
IN WHAT IT SAYS IS THOUGH THAT
THAT PERSON HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
TO TURN IT IN WITH IN TWO DAYS
WHEN WE INITIALLY WROTE THE
BILL.
WHEAT WE REALIZED AFTERWARDS
THAT THE ONLY.
REQUIREMENT OF COURSE WAS THAT
IT IS TURNED IN BY ELECTION DAY.
THE PROBLEM CAN BE WITHOUT OF
SOME BE HOLDS ON TO IT LONG TOP
TWO LONG IN THE VOTER GOES ON TO
SEE THAT THEIR VOTE WAS
REGISTERED ONLINE. THEY COULD
START TO BE ENSURE GET NERVOUS
AND AND WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
CERTAINTY IN THE SO WE WANT TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
IT SHOULD TAKE A PERSON A
VOLUNTEER A NEIGHBOR A FRIEND A
FAMILY MEMBER.
TO GET THAT EITHER IN A MAILBOX
OR TO THE REGISTRAR'S OFFICE SO.
RESPECT LASTED ABOUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OPEN UP THE COLLEAGUES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISS
HARPER.
I THINK VERY MUCH A IS YOUR CALL
AT SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT
YOUR BILL INITIALLY I'M. AND I
STILL REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS IS A IT IS IS A POTENTIALLY
INCOMPLETE AFFECTS.
UNIQUE ALSO REQUIRES THE
DESIGNATE TO
UPON THE REQUEST THE VOTER
PROVIDE THE VOTER WITH A RECEIPT
THAT INCLUDES THE NAME OF THE
DESIGNATION.
THE DATE AND TIME OF THE
COMPLETED VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
THAT WAS RECEIVED BY THE VOTER.
THE DATE AND TIME OF THE
ELECTION BY WHICH THE VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT IS BEING VOTED. THE
NAME IN THE ARE OF THE POLITICAL
PARTY CANDIDATES AND COMMITTEE
FOR WHICH THE DESIGNEES ACTING.
AND A TELEPHONE NUMBER AYE IT
WHICH TO DESIGNATE MAY BECAUSE.
CONTACTED.
A STATEMENT THAT THE VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT WILL BE DELIVERED
WHICH WILL ACTION PISTOLS WITHIN
THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR DEADLINE.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO AMEND
YOUR BILL TO BE ABLE INCLUDE THE
FULL PART OF THE I WILL BILL
THAT THIS IS INDEED SUPPOSED BE
MODELED NOW WE'RE NOT TRYING TO.
ADD ANOTHER BARRIER TO PEOPLE
TURNING IN YOUR BALLOT THIS
ASSEMBLY A AND I I ACTUALLY
DON'T RECALL IN AND PERHAPS
WHERE HEAVY TO DEBATES WHETHER
WE MODELED AFTER IOWA WE MIGHT
NOT A TIME PERIOD OUT OF IOWA
I'M WE MODEL THIS BILL AFTER.
COLORADO AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WE THEY'D ACTUALLY DON'T
HOW THE TIME PERIOD WE WENT
LOOKING FOR. A FIX TO THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IT IS BALANCE OUT THAT NEEDS
TO MAKE VOTING AS EASY AS
POSSIBLE TO REMOVE BARRIERS FOR
THE VOTER TO MAKE IT CONVENIENT.
TO NOT REQUIRE A STAMP TO TO
ALLOW FOLKS TO VOTE ON SAME TIME
SOME CERTAINTY FOR THE VOTER AND
AND THAT'S THE THE FACT THAT IF
THEY'RE GOING TO GO CHECK UM.
YOU KNOW THEY THEY CAN SEE THAT
THERE BALLOT HAS BEEN RECEIVED
IN A TIMELY MANNER AND AND THERE
THERE'S NO CONFUSION OR OR THERE
IS CONFUSION BECAUSE THERE'S
THEIR BALLOT WENT MISSING.
SO THIS IS JUST TRYING TO IT TO
TIGHTEN UP THAT TIME FRAME.
AYE I THINK THAT THE FULL
RECEIPT ISSUE WOULD CAUSE
ANOTHER BARRIER ONE WHICH IS
SOUNDS KIND OF REASONABLE AND
BECOMES VERY ARTIFICIALLY.
UNNECESSARY A VOTER IS AN ADULT
WHO CAN MAKE THE DECISION ON
WHETHER THE PERSON THEY'RE
ASKING THEM TO TURN IN THEIR
BALLOT THEY TRUST TO DO THAT.
THAT WE TRUST THE VOTERS I THINK
TO MAKE THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IN
THE FIRST ASSEMBLY RACE HELD
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF THE
PREVIOUS BILL ALLOWING ANY
PERSON TO PICK UP AND DELIVER
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS. REPORTS
SURFACED IN THE MEDIA OF OVERLY
AGGRESSIVE VOTE BY MAIL
DESIGNEES HARASSING IN COURSING
VOTERS INTO HANDING OVER THEIR
BALLOTS.
IN RESPONSE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
ALREADY GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. DEMOCRAT FROM CHULA
VISTA PLANS TO CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION NEXT SESSION. AT THE
VERY LEAST SHE SHOULD CONSIDER
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF BALLOTS
IN A SCENE R. SINGLE PERSON MAY
COLLECT AYE MAY COLLECT. AND
REQUIRING BALLOTS TO BE TURNED
AND SWIFTLY BY ELECTION DAY MORE
BROADLY LAWMAKERS SHOULD
REASSESS THE WISDOM OF ALLOWING
UNLIMITED AN UNVERIFIED THIRD
PARTY COLLECTION.
BEFORE THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CAMPAIGN BEGINS IN EARNEST AND
VOTER SHOULD BE ALWAYS WARY. OF
STRANGERS OFFERING TO BEAR AWAY
THEIR BALLOTS
THAT I EDITORIAL WAS CALLED
DON'T ALLOW VOTER PORTION AND
CORRUPTION TO TAKE HOLD IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MISTER
HARPER. IT I'M SORRY IF I'M IF I
MAY CLARIFY BECAUSE THE POINT
I'M MAKING IS THAT CRITICS A LOT
HAVE NOTED THAT THERE. IS NO WAY
FOR OFFICIALS TO KEEP TRACK OF
WHO BROUGHT IN THE BALLOTS AND
THUS THERE IS NO WAY FOR
INVESTIGATORS.
I TRACKED DOWN POSSIBLE CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS BY SUCH DESIGNEES AND
IF I MAY ASK.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE LA
TIMES CRITICISM.
TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF BALLOTS
EACH DESIGNEES MAY BRING AND.
AND REQUIRE SUCH DESIGNEES TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES TO BOTH THE
VOTERS.
FROM WHOM THEY COLLECT THE VOTE
BY MAIL LET'S UP VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS AND THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TO WHOM THEY DELIVER
THE BALLOTS.
I THINK I SHOULD INCLUDE THE
NAME ADDRESS.
PHONE NUMBER.
AND THE NAME FOR THE CAMPAIGNS
FOR WHICH THEY'RE WORKING AND
THE TIME AND DATE THAT THE VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOT IS PICKED UP
THOSE ARE THE SUGGESTIONS THAT
WERE BROUGHT BY THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES THANK YOU AND AND I
BELIEVE VERY AUTHORITY ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS ABOUT HAVING
EITHER DO. IT AGAIN
I I'D BE HAPPY AYE AYE I KNOW
THIS IS SURPRISING I DO NOT TAKE
MY DIRECTION FROM THE LA TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARD BUT NOW THAT I
KNOW YOU DO THERE PROBABLY
TWENTY I WILL DELIVER LATER
TODAY. TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
OPERATING LEGISLATION THAT THE
LA TIMES THINKS IS APPROPRIATE
UNFORTUNATELY IN ANY OF ANY.
ITEM ELECTION.
THE COMPLAINTS THAT SOMEBODY WAS
AGGRESSIVE WHEN THEY CAME TO MY
DOOR IT THEIR BALLOT USUALLY BY
THE LOSING CAMPAIGN
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
SOMEBODY DIDN'T HAVE A FIELD
PROGRAM WAS CONCERNED THAT
SOMEBODY CAME TO THE DOOR AND
ASK SOMEBODY'S GRANDMOTHER PAID
LIKE THEIR BALLOT RETURNED.
YOU KNOW WHAT VOTERS CAN SAY NO
THEY CAN SHUT THE DOOR IT
HAPPENS WITH PEOPLE WHO KNOCK ON
YOUR DOOR ALL THE TIME.
I M. HAPPY TO LOOK AT A PROBLEM
IF IT EXISTS THERE IS ZERO ZERO
ALLEGATIONS OF VOTER FRAUD THERE
ARE ZERO PEOPLE WHO SAID I VOTED
IT MIGHT VOTE DIDN'T GET
REGISTERED. THERE ARE ZERO
PEOPLE WHO SAID.
YOU KNOW THIS CAMPAIGN HELD
ONTO A BUNCH OF VOTES ARE EIGHT
ZERO. INFERENCE
THAT ACTUAL VOTER FRAUD EXISTS
IN I KNOW WHILE THE OTHER SIDE
MAY LIKE TO LIMIT VOTER CHOICES
BY DECLARING THAT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME.
I'M AT.
INTENTIONAL VOTER FRAUD SOMETIME
IN THE FUTURE THAT COULD HAPPEN
IN TELL YOU SHOW ME THAT THERE'S
ACTUAL VOTER FRAUD HAPPY WE DO
NOT WANT TO PUT ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS.
TWO PEOPLE VOTING I'M SORRY THE
MORE PEOPLE THAT BOTH THE BETTER
THE EASIER WE MAKE PEOPLE AND
THE OPPORTUNITY VOTE THAT THE
THE MORE COST WE TAKE AWAY FROM
VOTING THE BETTER IT IS FOR
DEMOCRACY AND NOW I WILL NOT
ACCEPT ANY AMENDMENTS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST TO CLARIFY
IN THE MEDIA REPORTS IT WAS NOT
THE LOSING CAMPAIGN.
OR LOS ANGELES TIMES AND OTHER
MEDIA OUTLETS ABOUT THE STRONG
ARMING IT WAS VOTERS THAT
COMMUNICATED DIRECTLY TO THE
POINT WHERE WORKING FOR LIVE
LOSING CAMPAIGN THAT'S RIGHT WE
CAN BRING OUR NEW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
UP AND WE CAN HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION MISTER HARPER ON THE
FLOOR ON FRIDAY BE HAPPY. TO
BRING HER OVER SO WE CAN HAVE A
AN AIRING OUT OF GRIEVANCES BUT
NO I WON'T ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY ASK
THE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY THE
AMENDMENTS DID NOT ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF LOS ANGELES TIMES AS
WELL AS THE I WOULD BILL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WE HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND. WE HAVE A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AT I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN
AYE ON THIS
VOTE I'M I'M I AM DEEPLY SORRY
IF I SUGGESTED WE SHOULD LOOK AT
THE MIDWEST OF WAYS TO REDUCE
BODY BARRIERS BECAUSE THAT'S
USUALLY NOT THE CASE BUT. I'M WE
ARE ONCE AGAIN TRYING TO ENSURE.
THAT BALANCE IS PROPERLY TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT AND I RESPECT THE
FBI BUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS A VOTER TO
DESIGNATE ANY TRUSTED PERSON TO
RETURN HIS OR HER VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT IF THE VOTER CANNOT DO
SO.
WHEN I VOTER INTEREST SOMEONE
ELSE WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
RETURNING HIS OR HER BALLOT THAT
VOTERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPECT.
THE BALLOT TO BE RETURNED TO THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL IN A TIMELY
MANNER I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT SUGGESTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. TO ENSURE THAT VOTERS
BALLOTS ARE NOT UNNECESSARILY
VALIDATED IN WITH THAT AMENDMENT
I RECOMMEND AS SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CULTURAL. EMOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE
HARPER IT HARPER NO CALDERONE.
CALDERONE AYE LOW. LOW AYE
MULLIN.
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOW WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
ITSELF WITH THE VOTERS FROM THE
FORTY TWO WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
YEAH.
COULD JUST MONNING.
I MEAN.
OKAY I'M AB SIX SIX FOR BY
STEINORTH.
CALLED AROUND. CALDERONE AYE.
MULLIN.
I AM ITEM THREE A PIECE SIX SIX
SIX BY ACQUIRE CURRY.
.
CULTURAL. CULTURALLY I LOW. LOW
AYE MULLIN
GOOD MORNING THE ABC.
SPIKE WIRE CURRY MISTER MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE YOU GET IT'S THANK
YOU.
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE OF MY BLACK
MALE HERE YEAH.
IS THAT.
AND THAT'S A GOOD PROBABLY.
WITH THAT THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU EVERYBODY